[موسيقى]
بدات اشعر انه اميل الى هذا الفن وانا في
التاسع من العمر
[موسيقى]
كان في الكالندر ليسمى التقويم للمطبعه
اللي تطبع هذا التقويم اسمه النصر كنت
دائما انظر الى هذه العباره تقويم النصر
مكتوبه بخط الثلث
طريقه كتابه الاحرف جربتني يعني شعرت
وكانه في هناك تحدي لتقليد هذه العباره
كان باب لتقويم خطي والنصر على الاعوجاج
في اي خط لكن بحكم الظرف المكاني والزماني
ما توفرت لدي الامكانات المطلوبه لتعلم
الخط العربي بعدين والدي فاجاني في يوم من
الايام
وبيشتري لي يعني مجموعه اقلام مع الرؤوس
المختلفه مختلفه الاحجام شعرت انه وصلني
كنز
قطعت من عام 96 عن الخط العربي 18 سنه كان
قطاع العاشقي عن عاشقته
[موسيقى]
صدفت خطات
وابهرني طبعا طبيعه خطه فهو تفاجا انه من
طبيعه طرح الاسئله عندي المام بالخط
العربي اللي يجب ان تعود الى الخط العربي
وعملت بنصيرته فقعدت الى الخط العربي
والان معي ثلاث شهادات خصوصا في خط النست
تعليق المسمى خطا الخط الفارسي
كتابه او تشكيل اللوحه تماما كشاعر يؤلف
قصيده او ملحن يؤلف مقطوعه
هناك علاقه روحانيه ما بين الخط والخطاط
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات